[Musique]
l'intelligence artificielle ou ya pour
les intimes
quand j'ai commencé à m'intéresser à ce
domaine de recherche je me souviens
c'était en hiver il ya longtemps c'était
pas très populaire les chercheurs en ia
c'est un peu les fous enfermés dans
leurs labos qui travaillaient sur des
théories qui avait aucune chance
d'aboutir
d'ailleurs quand j'ai dit à ma grand
mère que j'allais faire une thèse en
intelligence artificielle elle m'a
regardé les yeux pleins d'amour et elle
m'a dit je te félicite ma petite chérie
mais doit franchement tu veux faire quoi
comme vrai métier après sa voix la mamie
je tiens à te le dire en 2017 faire de
l'ia c'est comme être geek c'est devenu
cool super plaisant pour les chercheurs
en intelligence artificielle parce que
ça y est enfin la société s'intéresse à
ce qu'on fait c'est belle satisfaction
et en même temps c'est très agaçant très
agaçant d'entendre toutes les bêtises
qu'on raconte sur le sujet est
d'ailleurs agacé c'est ce que j'étais
quand j'ai vu cette couverture du new
yorker qui va apparaître
je vous assure elle va apparaître ou pas
voilà donc agacé c'est ce que j'étais
quand j'ai vu cette couverture du new
yorker qui a été réalisé par un artiste
il s'appelle kikuo johnson et je me suis
dit ça y est c'est reparti on va nous
raconter plein d'inepties sur
l'intelligence artificielle
puis j'ai réfléchi la couverture m'a
inspiré je me suis dit mais est-ce qu'on
pourrait en arriver là
est-ce qu'on pourrait arriver à une
société robotisée dans laquelle les
humains seraient laissés pour compte ou
pire parqués dans des eaux avec une
pancarte espèce en voie de disparition
autour du cou
la réponse est simple c'est oui on
pourrait en arriver là et si vous êtes
sceptique sur les possibilités
d'évolution de la technologie je vous
invite à vous poser une question ils
imaginaient que je vous met dans une
capsule spatio temporelle et je vous
envoie voir aristote vous arrivez vous
sortez votre téléphone de votre poche et
vous lui dites et regarde avec cet objet
tu peux parler en direct un gars qui vit
en orbite autour de la planète où si tu
préfères on peut regarder des vidéos de
chats à votre avis ils seraient ils
seraient sceptiques aristote
moi je pense qu'il le serait comme on
l'est par rapport à ce
tu évolues bon alors rassurez vous je
n'ai pas envie que ce scénario se
produise d'un autre côté je n'ai pas non
plus envie d'arrêter la recherche en
intelligence artificielle je veux
surtout pas m'interdire de travailler
sur des systèmes qui pourraient
améliorer notre quotidien nos relations
sociales la vie de nos aînés et pourquoi
pas même l'état de notre planète
donc la vraie question que je me pose
c'est comment on fait pour éviter d'en
arriver là et cette question je suis pas
la première à me la posent et prenez
asimov par exemple brillant écrivain de
science-fiction asimov il a imaginé un
monde dans lequel elle est dans lequel
les hommes et les robots peuvent
cohabiter et il ay s'amuser à créer
trois lois les fameuses trois lois de la
robotique pour éviter que ça tourne mal
et en fait cette mode de créer des lois
c'est ce qu'on est en train d'observer
dans la communauté scientifique chacun y
va de ses grands prix de ces grands
principes pour assurer que l'ia soit
bénéfique pour l'humanité mais moi je
crois pas que ça puisse fonctionner de
mettre en place des principes à mon avis
plutôt que d'imaginer des lois ce qu'il
faudrait qu'on fasse c'est qu'on
consacre toute notre énergie à
transférer à donner aux humains les
connaissances qui vont leur permettre de
comprendre ce que c'est que
l'intelligence artificielle
pourquoi parce que plus l'intelligence
artificielle progresse et je vous assure
elle progresse plus elle est difficile à
comprendre plus elle est difficile à
comprendre
et plus elle sera difficile à maîtriser
voyez par exemple au début quand on
faisait des systèmes intelligents on
utilisait des règles à ans paraissait
comme ça par exemple qu'on a fait des
systèmes qui sont capables de nous
battre aux échecs c'est des systèmes
assez simple à expliquer il avait une
tâche spécifique à accomplir jouer aux
échecs on pouvait expliquer comment les
règles avaient été construites qu'après
on compter sur la puissance de calcul de
la machine pour faire le boulot que nous
humains on n'est pas toujours capable de
faire ces tests et pratique c'était
compréhensible par contre l'inconvénient
c'est qu'il fallait penser à tous par
exemple si vous oubliez d'implémenter la
règle s'il ya le feu dans la pièce
arrête de jouer aux échecs et fuit pas
fallait espérer qu'il n'y a pas le feu
dans la pièce aujourd'hui la mode c'est
de créer d intelligence artificielle
qu'on entraîne à résoudre des problèmes
spécifiques comme par exemple
reconnaître des chats donc
on leur présente des milliers d'exemples
voire des millions d'exemplaires de
choses qu'il faut reconnaître et par
reconnaître on fait du calcul intensif
on les entraîne pendant des heures et
puis on espère qu'à la fin notre
intelligence artificielle sera capable
de reconnaître neuf chats sur 10 pour
vous donner un exemple c'est les
techniques qui sont utilisés dans alpha
go ce fameux programme qui a battu le
champion du monde 2 go il ya pas si
longtemps je vous donnais deux chiffres
alpha go il a joué cinq millions de
parties en trois jours sealys idole donc
le champion du monde qui a été battu par
alpha go avait voulu faire la même chose
il aurait fallu qu'ils vivent 1370 ans
bon alors c'est vrai que maintenant on a
des intelligences artificielles qui sont
particulièrement efficaces qu'ils
résolvent des problèmes bien spécifique
qui nous bat à plate couture dans plein
de domaines
ce qu'on a perdu par contre c'est
qu'elles sont beaucoup plus difficile à
expliquer on comprend moins ce qui se
passe à l'intérieur on n'a toujours pas
résolu non plus le problème de 6 à le
feu tu arrêtes de jouer tu fuis le même
problème principal avec les hyades
d'aujourd'hui c'est qu'il faut les
entraîner et que ça prend du temps que
ça prend beaucoup de puissance de calcul
et qu'à chaque fois qu'on s'y met on
fait fonds de 3 cm de manquer donc
l'objectif de l'ia pour l'avenir c'est
rdi ya qui auront plus besoin d'être
entraînée qui seront directement capable
d'apprendre par elle-même les
connaissances dont elles ont besoin pour
évoluer dans l'environnement
alors c'est sûr que pour l'instant elles
sont pas prêts de nous battre ni aux
échecs ni ogoni à d'autres jeux mais par
contre on espère qu'elles vont capa-l
vont être capables de découvrir par
elle-même que quand il ya le feu dans la
pièce il vaut mieux se carapater vite
fait et c'est cette nouvelle technique
d'intelligence artificielle qui me
passionne moins en recherche
ça s'appelle l'apprentissage
développementale c'est une approche qui
a inspiré de la psychologie en
particulier de ce qu'on sait sur la
façon dont les enfants construisent
leurs connaissances sur le monde en
interagissant avec le monde
quand on fait des robots
développementaux comme ceux sur lesquels
je travaille ce qu'on cherche à faire
c'est des robots qui sont motivés par
une seule chose leur curiosité et c'est
grâce à leur curiosité et leur
motivation qui vont explorer leur
environnement interagir avec nous
notamment et construire leurs
connaissances pour évoluer
alors bon c'est pas une idée neuve
l'apprentissage développement talent
fait turing en 1950 avait déjà évoqué
cette idée que
il serait probablement beaucoup plus
malin de faire une intelligence du
niveau d'un enfant et de l'éduquer que
de s'attaquer directement à reproduire
l'intelligence d'un adulte et je pense
qu'il avait raison on a juste mis 70 ans
avant d'essayer
alors maintenant imaginez une seconde
que j'ai raison de penser que la une
intelligence artificielle
développementale sera la prochaine
révolution en intelligence artificielle
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
que demain programmé désir à ce sera
plus l'apanage des scientifiques dans
leurs laboratoires de recherche qui
travaillent sur des théories qui
marcheront jamais mais ça deviendra de
la responsabilité de tous d'éduquer les
robots qui occupera notre quotidien ça
deviendra votre responsabilité comme la
mienne et si on veut le faire
correctement
éduquer ces robots il va falloir qu'on
apprenne comment il fonctionne
comment ils utilisent les valeurs qui
ont leur transmets comment ils
construisent leurs connaissances parce
que c'est leur curiosité qui sera le
moteur de leur apprentissage à vous
pensez peut-être que tout ça ça vous
concerne pas que c'est le futur que de
toute façon vous serez pas là pour le
voir et moi non plus mais en fait j'ai
un scoop pour vous avez tort
l'ia elle est déjà partout dans notre
quotidien depuis le fond de notre poche
dans notre téléphone portable jusque
dans la gestion de nos marchés
financiers et on l'influencent tous les
jours probablement à notre insu par les
données qu'on produit typiquement par
les photos de chats qu'on fait et qu'on
met sur internet par les choix qu'on
fait mais aussi par les choix qu'on fait
pas donc cette ia cette intelligence
artificielle elle est en train de
révolutionner notre quotidien
c'est un phénomène d'ampleur
significative
et puisque c'est un phénomène d'ampleur
significative il est essentiel que la
société soit bien armée pour pouvoir la
dresser pour pouvoir s'y intéresser
malheureusement pour l'instant c'est pas
forcément le cas il faut dire que les
gros titres de la presse qui mélangent
subtilement des mots scientifiques
compliqué qui font peur à tout le monde
des termes alarmistes des images issues
de la science fiction est en général qui
implique des robots qui tuent des hommes
ça contribue pas à éclairer le débat
tenez par exemple il ya quelques mois on
pouvait lire dans la presse grand public
unis à d
l'ope une forme d'agressivité quand elle
est contrariée ce qu'on vous dit pas
dans ce titre c'est que le but du jeu
pour l'ia c'était de gagner un jeu de
domination de territoire et donc pour
gagner elle a développé une stratégie
agressive je peux vous dire que si moi
j'avais dû me battre contre cette ia
j'aurais aussi développé une stratégie
agressive pour gagner quand même pas se
laisser battre par des intelligences
artificielles du ramassage de pommes
donc comme on fait comment on fait pour
avoir une forme de discernement parmi
tout ce bruit médiatique qu'on entend
autour de l'intelligence artificielle
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire en tant
qu'individu pour être créateur de
l'intelligence artificielle de demain et
pas être consommateur d'une technologie
qu'on va nous imposer pour moi pour
avoir les bonnes clés de lecture de
l'intelligence artificielle
il n'y a pas 36 solutions il y en a
qu'une et c'est l'éducation
il est impératif que la société s'empare
du sujet pour ça il est impératif que
les acteurs de l'intelligence
artificielle s'engage pour plus de
transparence et pour démystifier
d'intelligence artificielle et croyez
moi il ya déjà beaucoup d'initiatives
qui existe sur ce sujet des workshops
des écoles d'été des séminaires des
conférences des ateliers des expositions
ya même des gens qui montent sur scène
pour vous expliquer que c'est important
mais la plus grande responsabilité
c'est vous qui l'avez vous devez vous
emparé du sujet vous devez apprendre à
maîtriser les tenants et les
aboutissants de l'intelligence
artificielle comme vous maîtrisez le
téléphone portable que vous avez dans
votre poche
parce que si j'ai raison et que vous
devenez les éducateurs des robots de
demain vous avez intérêt à être bien
préparé alors je retourne la question
aujourd'hui
à votre avis est-ce qu'on sera des bons
parents pour les robots de demain mon
avis c'est que ça commence par être des
bons éducateurs pour la société
d'aujourd'hui parce que je sais pas si
l'hypothèse du new yorker est vrai ou si
elle est fausse
mais ce que je sais c'est qu'ensemble on
a toutes les clés en main pour éviter
qu'elle se produise je vous remercie de
votre attention
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]